harley quinn has been a fan-favorite
character for women and men of all ages
since she debuted Batman the Animated
Series way back in 1992 one look at any
comic book convention floor will tell
you she's easily one of the most popular
characters to cosplay in fandom but
Harley's history choices and morals make
her challenging is it wrong for fans to
love a character like Harley Quinn
[Music]
whether you see her as a dangerous
criminal or a well dangerous antihero we
wanted to talk with someone in the
mental health field about the black the
white and all the gray in-between about
fandoms love for Harley Quinn hi my name
is dr. Dre Ella - Mindy I'm a clinical
psychologist writer for fandom and host
of the podcast the Arkham sessions let's
jump right into it is our fandom around
Harley Quinn healthy you know we have
needs so Harley is a pop culture
phenomenon it's really interesting that
a character who is problematic can be so
popular I'm known to be quite vexing we
care about her and yet we know that she
represents all these kind of problematic
and difficult ideas one of those ideas
of course is her relationship with the
Joker and the clear understanding that
he's abusive toward her whether it's the
animated series or Suicide Squad any
iteration of her we've seen a pretty
long-standing narrative of the two of
them in an unhealthy relationship we can
feel adoration toward her we can feel
connection to her we can even feel like
we're like her and yet hold the idea to
that she's made some decisions that are
unhealthy and that she's a victim of
another character who
is never really punished for the ways in
which he's abused her certainly I think
it's it's possible that we want to see
her grow from this and we're kind of
rooting for her so there's this idea
that she will overcome some of the
darkness right and another piece of this
too is just being okay with something
that's this complicated if we look at
similar ways in which we're complicated
in which we've made mistakes I think
that we can begin to understand why
character like this is one that we can
accept
I think there's dimensions about Harley
that allow us to learn more about
ourselves and the different components
yes how we're good and how we're healthy
but also how sometimes we're not healthy
we don't make good decisions and we
might be in a situation just like Harley
so we're drawn to Harley because maybe
we see a bit of ourselves in her for
better or worse is that a lot to put on
a fictional character hell's wrong with
you people
so there's a concept called a parasocial
relationship and parasocial
relationships are non delusional
connections that we have with fictional
characters we know full well that
they're not real people but nonetheless
we have this pretty deep emotional
connection to the character I think a
lot of people have a pair of social
relationship with Harley Quinn the one
element of that of course is that we can
get rather close to her and feel pretty
safe that this is a character who can be
straightforward about her abuse who can
be straightforward about her mental
health who can be in that space with us
around some of these more difficult
histories that allow us to learn a
little bit more about our emotional
well-being one of the most helpful
aspects of a character like Harley Quinn
is that she gives us an opportunity to
think about our own mental health and to
examine our well-being and figure out
why we might be the way we are well
actors playing Harley changed almost as
often as our costume what would you
consider to be the most important
characteristics that she brings to this
parasocial relationship who is Harley
Quinn I think with a character like
Harley there are some core features that
need to stay pretty consistent Harley is
Harley when she's playful when she's
humorous when she's sort of
light-hearted in the way that she
relates to other people not to perfume
what is that the scent of death
underlying that is you know darkness
there that she's struggling to overcome
her past that she's wrestling with
really intense emotions and triggers
from previous experiences and then how
Harley looks I think might be something
that we think about too as far as her
appearance her seeming independence of
her body the seeming independence of her
sensuality and her ownership of herself
and I think that that's probably going
to manifest in different ways she
absolutely finds ways to really
demonstrate that self fulfillment and
that self actualization that comes from
within but there will be times when that
manifests as some kind of remnant or
psychological impact from the way that
she's been objectified I think that's
fairly accurate or common that when we
have experiences ourselves of being
objectified we then replay that out in
how we dress and how we talk to other
people and relate to other people in how
we look and so as we see this kind of
ebb and flow as we see this manifest
differently with Harley I think we we
could start to examine how her outward
appearance is some kind of
representation of what's happening
within without sounding too hyperbolic
or dramatic the idea of having that sort
of relationship but the character not in
charge of her own destiny seems
challenging after all her choices are
made by the people riding her do they
have some responsibilities and keeping
that relationship in mind Oh
own it so what happens when Harley's
glamorized in that she's presented as
kind of an antihero but also the figure
to adorn the figure to watch and follow
I do think it's important to ask what
happens when this connection to her this
intense fandom this adoration of her is
so widespread especially coupled with
her relationship with the Joker I do
think it's important to think about how
that presentation of a character could
impact the way that we address sexual
assault survivors the way that we
address women who are or have been in
relationships that have victimized them
anyone who could put up with mr. J
deserves a break and I do find it
problematic to glamorize that situation
and to create a hero with a clear
connection to victimhood I do find it
though to be helpful to be a part of
that dialogue for all of us to be open
to the kinds of conversations that come
from that it's not necessarily my
interest to correct or police or even
try to censor what creatives want to
portray what they have to say about some
of these characters but rather to pull
us into the room and have conversations
and dialogue about what those
connections mean it's so fascinating
that creative shifts can impact our
outlook on the characters so strongly
one take on Harley can be a fans anchor
and the next take there loudly
proclaiming not my Harley there will be
people that really want her to stay that
early version of who she was she was
always in relation to somebody else the
Harlequins role is just search
no one gives to us who we are beyond
death so in seeing a narrative where
she's in control and she's actually
directing and in power of her
decision-making and her own story will
be different for people and if you've
picked up that dr. drea feels pretty
strongly about dr. Quinzel you're not
wrong I have a really strong affinity
toward Harley Quinn I really really
connect with her I've connected with her
for like 30 years right so I do find
that personally I have to kind of
wrestle with what that means
how do I find a character so lovable and
yet understand that she's a
representation of victimhood and how can
I then examine that relationship and
what I feel toward her as a way for me
to then reconcile the nuances of that
victimhood if anything I hope that
there's benefit to more dialogue about
that and two different portrayal of this
character which we do have in various
iterations especially in the comic books
and in the new animated show where she's
able to kind of separate herself and
overcome her history of trauma it's a
complicated issue for a complicated
character and while no two experiences
with following her adventures will be
alike ultimately is it okay to connect
with Harley Quinn guys come on give me a
little credit here I think it's okay to
give ourselves permission to to be a fan
of Harley she's just so present in pop
culture
she really finds a way to get under her
skin and I I really like that about her
I think that that's particularly useful
or effective as a way for us to kind of
get into some feelings that are
important for us to examine in ourselves
it's a hard and sometimes really heavy
space to be in but I really appreciate
that she exists I appreciate that she's
there for us to share our our own
experiences together and and to be able
to have like a continued dialogue about
this while Harley's highs and lows may
be a bit more
extreme than ours it doesn't make ours
any less valid in fact as she navigates
both her past and the chaos of her life
Harley can help us feel safe to make
sense of our own even if we can't always
hit our own trauma with an oversized
mallet
[Music]
you